okay and welcome to this video yeah Adam
over yet we had set up here that look
really strange okay but and now the game
is going going on against the noid okay
okay let's see I'm going to go with this
crazy line again I really should study
something decent against the growing
fault I know but the day only has 24
hours let's see at least it seems that
he does not have already made answer
that he just dashes out this is some
kind of the idea well see takes and h5
also Helen comes into consideration yeah
typical green for green thought rule
fault counterplay d5 be five probably it
says idea it is not ok so I'm going to
take this as long as I've got the chance
yeah that's a somewhat slowish way to do
it now if I of course is a bit debatable
if I want to play that with them the
kind of firm and yeah the King in the
middle and pretty much committed to
queenside castling yeah Bishop f4
intends to go Queen d2 Bishop age 6 okay
so what is he doing here he wants to
probably play 95
okay I have to go from propecia page six
otherwise this whole setup it does not
make the faintest sense it's got all
kinds of temple moves with be 59 b6 yeah
black black seems ok yeah in a way you
should have this dynamic I want to play
typical of the green fault we should
have 395 this kind of moves yeah but ok
there is I've got the H file opened this
is a constant danger that that shouldn't
be completely underestimated
is taking this time now this is a
disconnect sometimes you think wow
that's a long thing no he's really
taking this long thing yeah okay I'm
going to take once at least and then
reconsider what I'm going to do ship
yeah okay Bishop Bishop takes you should
see three Quincy's reroute b5 there is
no made or anything on h8 so that's not
on night b5 head gives him a lot skit it
gives him lots of time this actually
also tricks might be 595 we should be to
Bishop takes f 3g takes rook takes be
five hahaha ok this is what he was was
what he was some thinking of all over
the time so I have to move it and back
then be five most likely who was strong
it is always difficult to say in such a
complicated term position so before now
is the the most obvious move getting
this temple but it's not clear that it
nets him that much yeah not it not clear
at all but if I go to a 4 he might play
route aaj that's a very awkward pin
night be fibers kind of kind of not
really our night 287 as a move if I go
night if for the wait wait why not rogue
aid I can Castle short it's not that I'm
not able to do that I'm not married to
any age far attack
yeah okay that's that's that's probably
probably the right square where the text
c5 from a strategic point of view this
is not such a bad position pawn
structure wise c5 is a is a weakness and
it's not so clear what is counterplay is
I mean maybe only form if I was
obviously weakened so Knight f6 is
something that has to be be checked but
you know this guy is playing even slower
than I am that's not easy to do if I've
well had that that really I didn't think
about it all night g5 looks very strong
first sight
well that really should be the right
move looking at a six it's not so easy
it cannot even move the night or some
night to a payer to ask where we're
disease where this is covered it really
looks problematic now
hmm now that will be very difficult the
time also is really much slower than I
am in this position right there hmm I
could just take on should I do that take
on g4 probably of the night only six is
so strong
now try and try to take on e6 I guess I
can
yeah I can also just go rook c1 looking
at this this week's e5 pawn and making
sure that I'm not in any any pin any any
time okay I can take now for Bishop g4
that is good I note that Queen age six
is still possible so takes this one jack
is quite cute black resign yeah yeah
that was was for very very tricky
position as usual for the age for movie
upon this line b5 was a very nice shot
this move here I went here and b5 her
funny move so I'm going to take and the
first point was this is this was the
easiest thing he can take here and win
the bishop why isn't that clear hey the
computer says it's just not so clear
interesting 92 because f3 is a threat
it's good for black but just zero point
something okay well i won't play that if
i go here um if i go there he has what
was my objection to that of course the
capture yeah 90s this is the the real
problem i thought that this is
interesting I'm sorry this is
interesting but Rami
ya know this is us the problem my droopy
5 this was the problem funny lineup
Bishop takes check and the Queen and if
I do something something else I mean
like this intermediate move is going to
take here and like wins yeah many
tactics but this wasn't that bad I guess
leucadia important is that after Luke a
time castling short sometimes you tend
to forget then when you have the open
age file or something some some some
early gained asset let's say like the
open file here that this is not the only
a tender position and here i think it
makes lots of sense to just castle yeah
he went f5 but just really should not
work right here why do in siem with the
with the night invasion and so probably
and probably i had a couple of good
continuations but this was jess was
definitely good enough yeah that was
pretty decent game I think thanks for
watching